good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of cabinet and I would say that
given we have speakers for the item
eight even navigation scheme we are
actually going to bring that forward on
the agenda so the people that are here
from that can leave so without any
further ado apologies for absence please
Thank You chairman council and I would
also like to offer apologies from
council Richards who was hoping to speak
on the avian navigation scheme item but
unfortunately he's in hospital so so
right minutes
oh sorry disclosures or interest yes I'm
sure we've all had countless emails
regarding item eight and I get record I
probably saved over 100 emails where
residents are giving their views I think
you are absolutely right council affair
will who have all had many emails and
much correspondence on the Evan
navigation I went through them this
morning and there are an awful lot so
right are you seeing that that goes for
all councilors good minutes confirm and
so in the minutes of the meeting held on
14th of January 2019 agreed Thank You
leaders updates I will be very brief on
the leaders update
right okay sorry we have an exempt
minutes
but just give people a couple of minutes
to read the exam two minute
this is in relation to cabinet on the
10th of December each minute 538 it's a
confidential minute yes
how people help you with the
confidential minute great thank you
and these will I believe be collected in
use not correctly okay in that case
moving on to me this update I just want
to make a few comments on the leader
statement I've just made a few changes
one neighborhood development plans to
delegate powers at all stages of the
process to down Pemberton as portfolio
older representation on outside bodies
local government intelligence unit
representative chris saying to replace
the leader and the delegation to Jackie
Howie's portfolio hold of the health
well-being and housing to make
amendments to the safeguarding and child
protection policy in console
consultation with the executive director
head of paid services so in that case we
move on to item 8 even navigation scheme
and this is to consider a report that
sets out the findings from the Aven
navigation scheme study which was
commissioned by the council Wallach
District Council and even navigation
trust councillor Cardin Thank You leader
this scheme was developed in
collaboration with Walker Warwick
District Council and considered by
cabinet in June 2017 as a potential
should already scheme that could deliver
increased access to canals and waterways
within the district in compliance with
section 2 CS 24 of the core strategy
there has been significant opposition to
the scheme and we have some speakers
before us councillor Richards as you
have mentioned and senses apologize
however he and his wife were taken to
hospital last night and we wish them
both all very well
may I suggest perhaps later that we
actually ask for some speakers now and
then I can carry on later on Thank You
councillor Cargill we have two speakers
councillor Chris Schroeder chairman of
Hampton lucy parish council and i
believe you are going to speak for no
more than one minute if you would come
up to the microphone I'll be grateful
and unfortunately you will be timed so
whenever you are ready if you press the
button on the microphone ready Thank You
chairman good afternoon cancers I am
speaking on behalf of Hunt and Lucy
parish council cabinet members should
have received an email with an attached
letter from the parish council which
explains clearly our position on this
matter and how it was being reached we
would like to add to this letter by
saying that we conserve not just about
the possible damage that this proposed
project could have within our parish but
also to the wider damaging effects it
will have on the whole unspoilt River
Valley between Alison Weir and Warwick
it will undoubtedly do long-term harm to
the ecology environment of the river its
floodplain
and surrounding land and will pose
significant risks at the listed historic
buildings and structures along it such
as ulsan house the old bridge at Warwick
Castle and in our parish the greatest
are listed Charcot middle and great to
enlisted Hampton Lucy bridge we request
that you reject the incremental approach
of recommendation - thank you for
listening may I make a suggestion that
he did that I think we have another
speaker would you like to stay at the
desk and then if there are any questions
they can be answered between the two of
you thought six oh that's fine thank you
thank you so we now have mr. David
Tucker mr. Ben ship stone who will
spread the remaining four minutes
between
when you are ready if you would press
the button on the microphone and just
let us know we'll start the timer
councillors chairman apologies for
bombarding you with information but both
the environmental and socio-economic
reports before you are marred with a
mission and fallacy my wife and I are in
aalverson house a great to Manor along
with one and a half miles of frontage of
the river close to the site of the first
proposed lock at tilling ttan up to a
quarter of a mile above the second at
Alveston this second lock is to be on
our private Millstream adjacent to the
house and garden not 600 metres away as
claimed the lockets concrete approaches
and moorings will destroy the settings
and visitor of the house garden part and
it's in the Alveston conservation area
all the facts totally ignored by Brett
and Luc the weir and locket inning
tomorrow's the water table by over two
feet and exacerbate flooding not just of
our land but many hundreds of acres of
land and property adjacent to the river
and indeed it will have impacts on
Stratford itself it's as inconceivable
that neither Luc nor Brett have been
pricked approached the Environment
Agency this despite the Halcro report
contacting 9e a consult EES who all
raised major ecological issues and
obstacles Paltrow said the
socio-economic and environmental reports
would resolve them
where are the flood maps where is any
research comparing navigable river above
Stratford to the below where is the
ecological detail of the EA project at
wasp button approved by this council a
year ago absolutely no mention at all is
this incompetence or something else the
legal opinion of David Hart QC totally
refutes the claim of a prior right of
navigation as prior as propaganda from
the Avon navigation trust it never
existed unfortunately the Haven
navigation trust claims have been taken
as fact not just by Halcro Bret and Luc
but by this council the opinion endorsed
by the National Trust and Warwick Castle
deals comprehensively with the legal
position far from 300,000
referred to as cost of legislation
assumed by Brett even 3 million will not
cover it and that's without compulsory
purchase assuming the Heritage in
ecology issues could somehow be resolved
this whole exercise stands discredited
and I urge you not just to note it but
to reject it Thank You chairman and
councillors I'm stringing grateful for
giving me the opportunity to speak at
your meeting my name is Ben shift and
I'm the National Trust assistant
director operations in the Midlands
region let me paint a little bit of a
picture for you the River Avon you know
well flows through the heart of
childhood poor walking by the river you
see a natural and historic landscape on
all sides the river fast flowing and
shallow historic buildings deer roaming
the park and crossing the river with the
far bank providing a refuge particularly
for dough's and forms and wildlife
including one of the largest Heron was
in the Midlands making use of trees
growing along the banks of the river to
build their nesting platforms this
precious place is enjoyed by over
200,000 visitors a year and we are still
very at this very moment investing 2.7
million to provide better Vista
facilities since the Avon navigation was
first muted in the 1970s we have
consistently set out what we feel is the
damage that this would cause to the
heritage and landscape and Wildlife
we protect on behalf of the nation and
which our visitors enjoy moreover a very
similar proposal was the subject of a
public inquiry by Warwickshire County
Council in 2004 where comprehensive
evidence from those for and against was
heard from and which resulted in
unanimous rejection by Warwickshire
County Council nothing substantive has
changed and said it is surprising that
neither the bricks or luc reports makes
any reference to this the environmental
review prepared by Luc only touches
those who certains but it shares our
concerns about inevitable harm to the
heritage of childhood this is an
extremely contentious project with many
challenges the estimated costs exclude
additional design planning compulsory
purchase legal or environmental reports
this section of the River Avon is a rare
survivor being a natural River in its
lower reaches but retaining much of its
untouched natural and wild States and
which is incredibly valuable for
wildlife
it also provides a backdrop to some of
the most important historic assets in
this part of Stratford and worried
including child to house mill warrant
castle all of which are important
economic drivers in there in the local
economy councillors not only is this
project not shovel ready in our opinion
it is not worth pursuing at all thank
you are there any questions from members
of cabinet for any of the speakers thank
you is it
yeah right right you've mentioned about
the environment impact on the reach can
you have some specifics because I think
mr. Tucker said that and can you confirm
this as it will raise the level of the
river by 2 feet okay Lucy
which will take it up and cause major
issues for the Miller who's here if you
ask questions he was registered to speak
as well as putting deeper water in front
of Charlotte I mean I think to answer
your question the key thing is that the
river along its length is at varying
depths in order to make it navigable by
boat you have to obviously have a much
more consistent level in order to do
that you have to raise the level in some
cases you won't be raising level but in
other cases you will have to raise the
level and in doing so that you are going
to upset the biodiversity of that river
system it's a very natural river I think
one of my colleagues had circulated
pictures to members of the council and
you can see how the the river is an
incredibly natural state an almost
untouched state if you then compare that
with sections of the river and canals
which are navigable
you find that the vegetation along the
side in many places is lost through the
traffic of boats going applying their
way up and down and also the need to
dredge certain sections to get the right
depth of water thank you
council house thank you yeah you
mentioned something about you had advice
from the QC about the rights of way can
you give us any more detail about that
which was very definitive in tackling
each and every one of the claim prior
rights of navigation some of the hearsay
that was dealt with defer and tailor the
water poet and more importantly the
legal acts of 1635 1732 which governed
whether the river who was actually able
to be navigated above Stratford
Stratford of course in 1640 was a very
small community it had hollow wolves and
that was the principal purpose of the
river in those days which sounds make no
evil the QC clearly defines the fact
that there was no proof of navigation of
but Stratford and possibly they've got
as far as to eat in a book
there's nothing about Stratford it
couldn't possibly have gone above
Alveston it was afford that rather 200
meters down the river which was only
direct out in 1962 that Ford was in the
domesday and five mils of towers been
recorded in the domesday book so the
legal battle of this and the claims that
a foundation trusts have made which
unfortunately being propagated because
everybody
they not being questioned and they not
being argued through in court that was
why I commissioned this DC's opinion
which was then put in terms of the
National Trust amaura Council voted to
put their legal people and my generation
thousands and thousands of pages were
searched from the body in the national
library water park Shakespeare
Birthplace trust all of this went into
it it wasn't just suddenly glory to
writing a two-page note he read
thousands of pages for the briefing
files were full filing cabinets full
it's probably as he said the biggest
river thing he's looked at in essence in
many cases and he embraced it fully and
has been incredibly helpful including
any more questions from cabinet in that
case thank you speakers and I'll hand
back to councillor Coggan thank you very
much yes thank you very much
right well I I've gone through the
report
I'm sorry counter kettle I was just
gonna say mr. chairman I had a I haven't
declared an interest in all the letters
when I received copies of them I did
receive one specific letters of the
Chairman which I forwarded to you from
Edmund Fairfax Lucy expressing major
concerns about the Peterborough report
you've had a copy of it I can go in more
detail if you wish to for your fellow
councillors but I'll leave that the mode
if you saw it I think not count
councillor Ralph
thank you I'm the ward member for
Alliston and I completely endorse what
dead attacker has said and obviously
I've seen the report from Warrick
District Council who turn to this
proposal down one thing I would like to
ask is how much our contribution was to
the to the report I mean how much did it
cost us for this report if that's
possible I could have that information
at some stage thank you we will find out
how much it cost and let you know counts
Takagi thank you right well I think I'm
almost summing up a little bit here I
think I too was disappointed in the
report I think it failed to explore the
arguments both for and against as well
as it could have done and as we know
there are a number of errors contained
within it so I think we can we can
accept all of that as mr. Tucker said I
can find no compelling argument that the
river has been open to general
navigation previously and I don't know
how far back you want to go in time but
yes certainly in many lifetimes business
case isn't interesting because I think
it was quite weak and again not
compelling and there's a huge potential
cost to open the navigation up and my
argument would be who's going to pay for
it well I do feel that although it'd be
nice to open up the navigation for
tourism and health and well-being and
all those things it seems a heck of a
lot of money and it's not a potentially
justifiable cost at this time so I'm
very unhappy about that
I do how I believe that will be an
impact on the residents the landowners
and the business units users and that
would be adversely impacted finally I've
got to say that I feel from the
environmental point of view that there
would be potential harm there and that
would outweigh any business case the
has been presented to us so for that I
cannot support this report at all the
footpath
however it's slightly different that has
got some potential a suggestion was made
that we consider a report to open at the
footpath between Stratford and Warwick
as we are not the footpaths of authority
I've suggest members that that is sent
to County for consideration right one
thing I would say is that I would like
to draw a line under this because I can
imagine that most people who have been
impacted by this wouldn't want this
cloud hanging over them into the future
so as far as I'm concerned leader I
think we should draw a line under this
one and not progressing any further 81
councillor tardy and we sticking with
these recommendations or are we amended
I would like to amend them please
neither
yes the first recommendation that the
study setting out the a high level
assessment of environmental and
socio-economic impacts of the proposal
to extend the even navigation scheme
from Stratford Alliston to Warwick is
noted however I would like to change the
second item please that no further work
is undertaken by SDC staffer district
council to progress the scheme other
than to make a representation to work
the County Council to promote cycleway
and footpath improvements along the Avon
corridor between Warwick unstructured
now I'd appreciate everyone's agreement
on that please
targil any comments on the revised
recommendations sorry from cabinet
members
he's cabinet happy to approve the
recommendations as amended on page one
eight warn and as outlined by councillor
Cargill thank you
cabinet in that case those
recommendations are agreed and it is
worth saying that we have noted the
report that we're no further work
undertaken my SDC to progress the scheme
with that I think we'll take a five
minute recesses the people who so the
people who came for this particular
agenda item can leave if they wish
Cavan it is back in session
are we moving on to item for revenue and
capital budget 2019-20 councillor organ
Thank You chairman attached to the
report are the the draft Capitol report
is attached as an appendix four to this
agenda item and that's on page 27 and
the new bids for funding are shaded for
ease of identification and the draft
revenue budget table is on sixty-seven
again with proposed growth and savings
shown shaded and the details of these
are on page 68 this year the revenue
support grant ends completely so we
don't have any next year however the
rural services delivery grant remains
for the year the major source of income
to the council which is new homes bonus
has been confirmed for the next year
however it is forecast to reduce
significantly over the medium term the
draft budget for nine 2019-20
is based on accounts of tax increase of
1.5% and shows a four thousand three
hundred and sixty-four pounds surplus
this is a prudent budget that aims to
maintain a sound financial structure for
the future and key objectives are kept
or to keep expenditure at sustainable
levels within available resources whilst
making realistic provision for inflation
etc and ensuring early recognition of
emerging issues consultation has taken
place on the draft budget proposals with
the public by the council citizen panel
and the appendix is here yesterday with
the council's overview and scrutiny
committee and with local businesses by
the nnd our forum
I commend the recommendations on page 15
to agree the medium-term capital and
revenue budgets
and to set council tax for 2019-20 at
139 point 12 for a band dean property
which is a 1.5 percent increase Thank
You chairman Thank You councillor organ
any questions or comments from members
of cabinet
no no just okay some real questions or
input from cabinet councillor Morse
Gemini I think both in County and the
police have now agreed their increase
and this council will no doubt do so
fairly shortly in the February council
meeting AB and D payer apart from that
parish in town precept will be asked to
pay an extra ninety four point two four
pounds a year now that works out
chairman at five point five three
percent CPI inflation dissemble is two
point one percent so I wonder chairman
if you share my dismay the council
taxpayers are being asked to pay a five
point five percent increase two and a
half times more than two and half times
the rate of inflation so firstly
Chairman I wonder if you share my dismay
at that and secondly it's about the
consultation chairman looking at the
people who have replied two thirds of
the people who replied are over 60 at
the same time 52 percent of them are
wholly retired from work chairing this
is not a fair sample of the population
in our district and I wondered what we
can do in future to get a more
representative sample replying thank you
Thank You councillor Morse if I could
respond to the first point first which
seems moderately logical one of the main
increases this time around in council
tax has been the police precept
there was a very extensive consultation
process on the police preset with I
think speaking from memory something
like 2600 responses
the overwhelming majority of those
responses supported a 24 pounds increase
or higher and the police and crime panel
at last week endorsed the 24 pounds
increase I think when it comes to
policing in particular people are happy
to pay the extra and I would just add
the proviso that says they want to see
more visible policing the remainder of
the precept is I think County Council
and where they did a was it four point
nine percent four point nine nine
percent obviously we are not in control
of the County Council precept and an
awful lot of that I believe is to fund
social care so two percent of that is to
fund social care so obviously there are
special reasons why council tax has
risen so much this year I have to say
they've been stink tively I am not in
favor of high taxes but I do understand
the reasoning why those are there and
ours one should remember he's going up
one and a half percent it is not going
out by 24 pounds and it is not going up
by four point nine nine percent
Chancellor Pemberton a hue indicated a
wish to speak I think Thank You leader
in many walks of life one of the good
there's a good maxim that talks about
controlling the controllables and the
things that we can't control are the
police precept and the County Council
this Authority delivers the services
that it delivers and let's just nail
this this is a 1.5 percent increase for
the services that we deliver okay
people have to pay for other services we
cannot influence and control what other
authorities do we're merely the
collection agency so just so this is
loud and clear the District Council
taxpayers look at the district can the
district taxpayers are paying an extra
1.5% for the district
council services and there was
overwhelming support in terms of that
approach from the citizens panel even
noting some of the questions around the
the the spread of the citizens panel in
fact actually that might suggest that
they would be less likely to accept so
if that that demographic would accept
then you know perhaps you might even
suggest that maybe maybe not but it's
one and a half percent and that's what
we're in control of and it's delivering
the services of our people in this
district want us to deliver that's
really what I want to make clear Thank
You councillor Pemberton just picking up
the responses of the citizens panel I do
that now I see can't mr. Buckland Peters
point around the representation of the
responses and a citizen panel is broadly
representative of those people living
within our district we have had a record
number this time actually replying
online as opposed to hand completely
question now is it busted
unfortunately I can't account for people
to respond to to the questionnaire and
whilst the makeup of the whole panel is
representative those who have responded
have been slightly more older people
though I say that than the board of
representation so we will encourage to
try and we'll continue with your view to
try and get as many dumped online and
they encourage younger people to respond
unfortunately that is who has responded
to this questionnaire thank you mr.
Buckland just looking at the response to
the citizens panel I do notice on page 7
of the response or page 8 as it could be
the extent to which residents feel SDC
offers value for money 90% who rated it
very good or good which i think is an
absolutely excellent result no money
comments or questions then can i refer
cabinet to the record
and Asians on page 15 can I have your
agreement to those recommendations
recommendations one and two or two
cabinet and recommendations three four
and five offer us to recommend to
council all in agreement thank you
cabinets moving on now to item five
prudential indicators and once again it
is council organ Thank You chairman the
setting of prudential indicators is to
ensure that capital investment plans of
local authorities are affordable prudent
and sustainable the calculation of the
indicators is mandatory and contained
within the report are the proposed
indicators for Stratford district
council thank you any questions are any
debate from members of cabinets I'll
take that as a resounding no in that
case the recommendation on page 79 can I
have your agreement to the
recommendation on page 79 please come in
it thank you
moving on to item six and I find it
treasury management strategy statement
councilor organ yet again Thank You
chairman council is also required to
draw up an annual treasury strategy
which is in line with both adi CLG
guidance and the zip code of practice
this includes the council's capital
plans a minimum revenue provision policy
how investments and borrowings are to be
organized and how in
are to be managed the proposed treasury
management strategy is attached at
appendix 1 on page 90 and this details
which investments the council may use in
addition it limits the council's overall
borrowing to 20 million including the
council's short-term borrowing limits of
10 million and permits variable interest
rate on borrowings the council currently
has no plans to borrow in order to meet
its a medium term financial plan however
there is a requirement to set limits
regardless of whether or not there are
plans to borrow the council is required
to approve a minimum revenue provision
policy statement and this is included
within section 2.7 of the report the
recommendation is to approve option 2
which details that minimum revenue
provision will be based on the capital
financing requirement and option 3 which
bases minimum revenue provision on the
estimated life of the asset council is
also required to approve the annual
investment strategy and this is included
in part 4 of Appendix 1 which is on page
105 this states which investments the
council may use for the prudent
management of its Treasury balances in
addition to all this this year is the
first year of a new strategy which is
the capital and investment strategy and
this is included as Appendix 2 on page 1
1 3 and this statement provides both a
framework and a mechanism whereby
capital expenditure and investment
decisions are aligned over the
medium-term period and ensures that all
new funding is targeted at meeting the
priorities of the council
whilst ensuring that the council is
aware of risks associated with such
activity and I commend the
recommendations on page 85 white members
of cabinet are there any questions any
observations are any discussion once
again I will take that as a resounding
no and in that case cabinet can I have
your agreement to the recommendations to
Council as outlined by councilor organ
and set out on page 85 thank you members
of cabinet so we now move on to item 7
which is the development requirements
supplementary planning document adoption
of Part Q or a kid's district heating
networks closed brackets councillor
Pemberton thank you thank you leader as
members of cabinet will be aware the
we've been bringing various sections of
the district development requirements
supplementary planning documents to
cabinet for approval and this is the
latest in in that line this is part Q
which deals with district hating
networks and enables further guidance to
be given to support the core strategy
policy CS to climate change and
sustainable construction and cs3
sustainable energy a number of parts of
the SPD have already been adopted and
really just looking for confirmation
from cabinets that Park you be adopted
as part of the development requirements
supplementary planning document happy to
take any questions Thank You councillor
Pemberton any input debate or questions
from members of cabinet in that case
members of cabinet can I have your
agreement to the recommendation to
Council on page one to nine thank you
in that case can we move to agenda item
9 which is the Cotswolds area of
outstanding natural beauty management
plan 2018 to 2023 councillor Cargill
Thank You chairman this is a report
produced by the AM ob8 oh and I always
get that wrong
a OMB in relationship that their
ambitions for the actual area the the
the whole point of the natural beauty of
this particular area obviously the
Stratford district has an element a
small part in that in that area the OMB
and this is why we have been asked to
cut to endorse the report in general I'm
very happy to do so and I also note that
we do have representation on the board
that drafted it so again we've had an
input into it I think the only concern
that in the report ambition for states
that they would like to establish
national park status for the AO and the
area that may have some implications for
us as a planning authority in the future
or may not I think this is one of the
things which we don't know about so I'm
making a suggestion that we reword the
recommendation slightly leader I would
like to propose that the recommendation
reads that the council reserves its
position in relation to ambition for of
the consoled AO nd management plan to
establish national park status for the a
OMB area pending the publication and
consultation of the consult a OMB
board's position in relation to this
otherwise I'm happy enough to endorse
this I just be making absolutely clear
what the recommendations are there
Commendation on page 187 the Cotswolds
area of outstanding natural beauty
management plan 20 18 to 23 be endorsed
and in addition the additional
recommendation is that the council
reserves its position in relation to
ambition for of the Cotswolds AAA oh and
be management plan to establish National
Park stages for the a or n be pending
the publication and consultation of the
Cotswolds a or NB boards position in
relation to this any questions or
comments and come in it just before you
and discuss the revised recommendation
if I can just draw your attention to
paragraph 5.1.1 legal implications at
the top of page 189 unfortunately the
wrong legal underpinning has been placed
into the report I've got a revised
alternative it is a little bit of a
mouthful but if you can just grant me a
few seconds right so that the
replacement wording would be the council
needs to take into account the
provisions of section 4 84 and 85 of the
countryside and rights-of-way Act 2000
when exercising or performing any
functions in relation to the conserving
or enhancing of the natural beauty of
the a n OB the clock has got a copy of
that so this name yes please
council darker amusingly The Crow Act I
was involved in drafting a load of the
amendments to it so not only was I
involved in that piece of legislation
but I sit on the COTS holds a OMB and I
just like to reassure you that the
process to become a national park is so
long and tortuous that you're not going
to be changing the planning process here
any time soon however I would appreciate
it as a memory serves on this monstrous
board of the a OMB
if there was something in here that made
it sound like you were being a teeny
tiny bit more supportive because I'm
very conscious that there are bits of
this district which are right on the
periphery which get hammered with
developments and they are very far away
from us
they are even further away from Warwick
and they certainly feel that in County
Council terms and because they're on the
periphery they also unbelievably all
that all of them like Braille on Compton
which furred happen to be in the area of
outstanding natural beauty so it does
give a little bit more clout to what
they can do in planning terms and this
is one of the things that has
underpinned why we want to become a
National Park because that will give it
a lot more clout particularly for these
fragile places and don't know how many
of you are familiar with them on ultra
familiar with them but they are the sort
of places that we really do want to
conserve so I just say that if you were
minded to be supportive that would be
very very helpful Thank You councillor
Barker can we put in the minutes
what councillor Barker has just said and
I would it be fair for Pemberton sorry
just thank you thank you just listening
to what Council Barker has had to say my
reading of this is that we're we're
merely reserving our position in terms
of that particular ambition until we
have an understanding of the board's
view on that it's because I've really
got two questions and perhaps councillor
Parker might be able to help us with a
do we have any sense of the direction
the board wants to go and B do we do we
have any understanding of when they're
likely to come to a view on that because
they're presumably what councillor
Barker would be looking for is for us to
revisit ambition for in terms of that at
the terms of this document and then to
clarify our position on it can I just
clarify yes that we are only reserved in
our position
in relation to ambition for not to
everything else that's absolutely clear
counselor Barca do you wish to respond
we had a humdinger of a row at the last
IOM be bored me and a former Liberal
Democrat MP who came to his first
meeting and decided he didn't like the
idea the National Park and was quite
surprised to meet someone who strongly
opposed that view the majority of the a
OMB Board for ages we've been talking
about becoming a national park that's
been our ambition and it was only at the
last meeting that a span it was slightly
thrown in the works but the conclusion
was that we're still going for the
status the problem is that there will be
there are potentially changes to the
status of national parks and we're
looking at that at the moment so it's
ongoing really sorry it just takes
forever do you think we take a long time
thanks Chancellor Barca comes with
Cargill you wish to respond thank you I
think accepting the fact that it is
aspirational and there's a long process
to go through I'm quite happy with that
what I would perhaps say or make a
suggestion leader is that we might wish
to reword slightly our recommendation to
say we fully support the document that
has been presented to us I'm quite happy
to do that later
[Music]
I'll just be clear we fully support the
document with the provider that we
reserve our position in relation to
ambition for ya Brogan yes chairman I
think I'm I'm very happy with that I
understand completely what the Cotswolds
area of outstanding natural beauty
management board wish to achieve and I
think it is the right direction for for
them to be seeking but I also think that
the council has a responsibility to
reserve its position on on this on
matters that do directly impact on the
council itself and I don't see that the
the board will be particularly upset
about that I think they would consider
it to be a natural response thank you
Thank You councillor bar could you wish
to respond just as long as you look
entirely supportive when in about 20
years we achieve here that'll be fine I
think we can work on the assumption many
others will be here at that so with that
reworking of the additional
recommendation are we happy to support
the recommendations on page 187 on the
revised recommendation that was read out
great thank you ten members of cabinet
so we now move on to item 10 council tax
premium empty homes this
counselor house is not here so I will
take this item and I just want to say
that in 2013 the government introduced a
levy on council tax for properties that
have been empty for over two years this
is 50 percent of annual liability in
March 2018 demanded the legislation to
allow this levy to be increased to a
hundred percent of the annual liability
from April 2019 over 290 councils
operate the levy scheme and at the
moment in this district around 200
properties currently have to pay the 50
percent levy the increasing levy could
raise in the region of an additional 186
thousand per year in council tax that
would give Stratford district
unfortunately only another 15,000 all
the current exemptions would continue to
apply and it is worth saying the
council's affordable housing delivery
group have pledged their support to the
proposals so looking up the
recommendation on page 195 that an
increase to the council tax premium on
empty properties being that an increase
yes to a hundred percent of liability
from 2nd of April 1st of April 2019 he's
agreed capsular cargill just one thing
for mr. Platts obviously I support this
process and the and the trajectory we're
moving in but just to clarify that this
will be on a case-by-case basis because
inevitably there will be some people who
won't the conditions or circumstances
might be awkward for them for a reason
I'm thinking of perhaps people who've
passed away and
how they can actually get the houses
solved and suchlike so I'm just thinking
yes that's absolutely right the
exemptions are in the report if there's
a if this probate being awaiting on the
property or the property is also and in
you in those circumstances then they
they applies the exemption 5 thank you
moving on now to item 11 Clifford
chambers and milk Neighborhood
Development Plan pre-submission
consultation responses councillor
Pemberton Thank You leader I also see
that Casa Barnes has indicated a wish to
speak perhaps just to introduce the item
the Clifford chambers and milk at
Neighborhood Development Plan has now
reached the regulation 14 pre submission
consultation stage where the NDP group
are seeking formal responses to its
draft plan from us as an authority and
the responses set out I think at that
point it looks as though counselor
Barnes and his significant other are
ready to address the cabinet councilor
Barnes four years ago when there was an
election we had no parish council at
Clifford
we did explain that there was need for a
plan haven't got your [ __ ] with you
every today I get on the do dog do I
just say this is being broadcast
there was no parish council they don't
resigned we had a number of meetings we
got an exceptionally good chairman who
took on this job he's taken him four
years to do it a lot of work has had
help from other parish councils but now
we have if you like saved the area not
only to thank him but his team I've done
one or two meetings there but I think it
is appropriate that a lot more work has
to be done to get it where we are
it's nearly there but it's virtually is
there and it will say about village
that's as much as I need to say but we
must thank everybody for a lot of hard
work in the short time they've got their
website and everything and we have moved
forward Thank You councillor Barnes any
questions any comments from members of
cabinet in that case it was really just
that we reiterate and and note this
authority in this cabinets thanks for
the work that's been done on on getting
the NDP to this to this particular stage
and hopefully then they can work
together with the with the proposed
amendments to get the to get to the
referendum stage as soon as possible
Thank You councillor Pemberton with that
the recommendation on page 199 cabinet
happy with that a great Thank You
members of cabinet's moving on now to
item 12 which is prized Mastan parish
plan councillor Pemberton again thank
thank you leader so this lady surprised
masters pipes like priors
Mastan parish plan and is now ready for
it to be adopted and used as a material
consideration when determining planning
applications in accordance with course
truck core strategy policies and
therefore there's an important source of
local information and
ground when supporting parish councils
outside the district council in
applications in in priors
Mastan this follows on from a review of
their existing plan in 2005 and though
was a two hundred and fifty
questionnaires distributed 178 completed
which is a response rate in excess of
70% which is an extremely extremely
pardoning response so again with the
noting the thanks of this cabinet in
this district council to the work that's
done to create the purge plan
recommending that the cabinet's accepts
the recommendation that is found I've
just lost my page apologies on 207 that
it be adopted as a material
consideration thank you
Thank You councillor Pemberton any
questions or any discussion from cabinet
councillor kettle thank you the council
person was always encouraging for any
agency any community working together to
produce these documents I think it'd be
helpful for those who are considering
either producing an NDP or the parish
plan how much planning weight can be
given to a parish plan because we're
told that Neighborhood Development Plan
has significant weight but I think it'd
be helpful for communities to hear what
what level of support can be put on on
that to respond thank you I mean as as
as the chairman will be aware there it's
not quite as straightforward as saying
that if it's an NDP you know get sort of
80% weight if it's a plan it's 50 or 60
percent weight whatever it might be
I mean it is true to say that
neighborhood development plans you know
by their very nature because they that
they particularly impact on on on larger
settlements do carry more weight in the
process but I think just to give some
assurance that the
not a sort of two-tier approach taken by
officers in relation to communities that
have got a parish plan I think it is
fair to say that officers will always be
cognizant of the the parish plan that's
in place bearing in mind that there is
still that level of engagement between
local communities in preparing their
parish plan in seeking advice and
support from policy officers so parish
plans are generally in conformity with
course strategy I think really it's just
saying yes they carry weight yes you
know and reinforcing the message to all
communities where it is where they have
sufficient mass or scale to to either
choose parish plan or the Neighborhood
Development whichever is appropriate for
their kin their communities that they
should do so because they are they are
invaluable documents and sources so I'm
happy to give the assurance to the chair
and would be happy for us to if
appropriate get that message out to all
all of the parishes that have yet to
adopt either a plan or a neighbor
development plan or a parish plan so I'd
be happy to write to two relevant PO
systems about to beat the drum if you
will in to reinforce that they do have
support of course each individual
application has to be dealt with on its
merits as the head of the service then
kicks me in the ankle to remind me Thank
You councillor Pemberton in that case
the recommendation on page 207 is
covered it happy with the recommendation
on page 207 agreed thank you
moving on to agenda item 13 CCTV CCTV
upgrade project exceptions general
provisions of contract Standing Orders
rubra 12 brackets one appointment of
Beattie
councillor Harris thank you leader this
won't take very long
it's fairly straightforward it's just
generally become for you because
the amount involved in the contract and
the fact that we're appointing just one
company
I think the document speaks for itself
it's seeking support for the exception
to the general provisions of contracting
standing orders under Rule 12 one
highlighted for the upgrade of bt fibres
as part of the CCTV upgrade project and
the recommendation is quite clear that
there is a request for this exception
Thank You councillor Harris is cabinet
happy with the recommendation on page
211 thank you cabinets so now all that
remains is there are no issues arising
from overview and scrutiny they on block
items please note the cabinet work
program which has been circulated they
affordable to come network program they
affordable housing delivery working
group and councillor Cobden I think you
wish it's just a commonplace leader we
are struggling apparently to get hold of
orbit because that was what we were
discussing at the last meeting and I'm
very reluctant to delay the next meeting
which I think we should really press
this forward because it's so important
let's fit in that orbit fit in with us I
think to a certain extent because I'm
reluctant to just pause the process
until orbit decide they can turn up now
I agree with that because we have tried
to put them with the business
considering the way they came forward
with their ideas we thought they'd be
willing upfront and they would slot in
and they just been elusive so I agree
yes as I understand orbit were prepared
to attend the meeting was rescheduled
for finally the eighth of February we
have moved that meeting and it's no
longer being held on that day so I think
we have to work with them as well as
then working with us on that particular
point give them a few options though and
I haven't come back in delusive point
noted in that case counselor kettle
Thank You chairman as part of the terms
of reference of this this group I think
it's very important to recognize that
there is a certain urgency for this
whole scheme to move forward some of you
may be aware that I met with one of the
local directors of orbit at the
beginning of last week and have
circulated a minute of that meeting to
mr. Buckland and the portfolio holder
comes to Harris and I think chairman of
our scene whereby they have identified
orbital identified a significant number
of properties which are for disposal and
many of these properties are in local
communities which are remote from the
larger settlements some of those
properties have already been sold other
properties are going to be sold
I think council councilor kettle this is
purely about the minutes those issues I
think should be raised with the group
fair enough thank you thank you so any
items of urgent business in that case
meeting closed